am 31 oktober soll es tatsächlich
endlich soweit sein der br geht
offiziell in betrieb
heute findet zum letzten mal ein
komparsen test am flughafen statt um
herauszufinden ob auch jetzt wirklich
alles funktioniert das lässt sich bild
natürlich nicht entgehen und ist dabei
johannes malinowski ist mir nun
zugeschaltet von pannen flughafen
herr johannes erzähle uns ist es noch
immer der pannen flughafen oder lief
jetzt bisher alles reibungslos bald
einen test also es heute der finale test
es gab es dieser grad fest hieß nennt
mit bis zu 400 komparsen jetzt den
ganzen sommer über schön durch und wenn
heute nicht alles klappen sollte hat ja
flughafen tatsächlich ein problem ich
habe in der vergangenen woche manchmal
mit dem flughafen schafft mit einer
bergbesteigung unterhalten und er ist
tatsächlich ganz optimistisch das ist
dieses mal tatsächlich so weit sein wird
das am 31 oktober die ersten zwölf
flugzeuge landen werden ganz
optimistisch das klingt eigentlich ganz
gut aus sondern die geschichte vom br
kennt kann denn jetzt noch was schief
gehen gibt es noch immer sachen die auf
der liste stehen die irgendwie repariert
werden müssen ersetzt werden müssen
et cetera wie wir das alles schon aus
der vergangenheit kennen also wenn man
sich den flughafen anguckt die
infrastruktur die es soweit fertig
natürlich die leben werden eingeräumt im
vorbereich und terminal gab es jetzt in
den vergangenen tagen noch bauarbeiten
hat wurden auch schranken eingebaut das
sind alles so kleinigkeiten die noch
gemacht werden müssen aber toi toi toi
dreimal auf holz geklappt am 31 los und
sowohl die flughafengesellschaft ist er
optimistisch und als laien ein um das
ist eine sehr sehr sehr gut stand ein
richtiges glück gehabt nach hausinternen
mitsamt geht
er wisse von vielen dank johannes für
diese 1 zurück mal sehen ob's am 31 sind
dann was wird dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren